uh let's go to Sammy from New York City
Sammy welcome to the program welcome
back I should say
oh hi David hi
can you hear me yes I can
thanks for I'm taking my call this is a
question not really about politics but
sort of
um
why is it that
um in healthcare the dental
um coverage is it included in health
care and isn't that something good that
a politician could run on is trying to
get that into place because dental
health is so important
this is a major issue which is a lot of
people say
why is it that dental health insurance
is typically not included except for
children by default in health insurance
why have we taken this one aspect of
Health oral health and said this one
thing is separate it's a completely
completely separate thing it doesn't
really make any sense and there are all
sorts of historical reasons involving
monied interests and lobbyists Etc as to
why that's the case the quite frankly
the answer is it should be all part of
the same thing there's no reason people
should have to get separate dental
insurance it also by the way by making
it a separate thing suggests to people
you've got all your real Health stuff
here and then there's kind of like this
other thing which is dental health it's
not really that important it's separate
that's why we've categorized it
separately which is completely wrong so
it's basically money money in health
care is the reason why by default dental
insurance is not included and by the way
I have not had
uh dental insurance for
um I guess it's 12 years since I went
off of my parents Insurance because I
went to my dentist at that point and I
said you know with tears in my eyes I
can't I'm you know big strong guy my
dentist is a big strong guy and I said
to him uh I'm go I'm gonna lose should I
be buying because I'm self-employed
should I be buying this health dental
insurance and he started crying and said
with tears in his eyes if you can
believe in Sammy I wouldn't do it you
know your dental health is pretty good
think about it you've got two cleanings
a year I tend to get little cavities on
average you've got a couple little
cavities a year that's at the time that
that was like 500 bucks the dental
insurance would have been the exact same
amount but it only covers up to a
maximum benefit of like 1200 bucks so
there was this tiny window where the
dental insurance made sense so I've
self-insured on elements of dental ever
since and I'm fine with it but let's be
honest it should be part of health
insurance
oh yeah because so many people like they
don't go to the dentist it uh uh brings
on so many other health issues that you
you don't you know you people might
think are not related but it's your
whole body it's your whole Wellness
absolutely and it's it's so important
and it's just something because I just
went to the dentist too and I was like
thank God everything's good but I'm just
like what's with that you know why isn't
it combined it's yeah it's really so
annoying and I think in a lot of ways
it's something people don't really even
think about like yeah why are they
combined why are they not combined
absolutely um yeah and it's something
maybe
um again maybe a politician might bring
that up at some point I don't know but I
have heard it brought up and I Am with
You Sammy I appreciate you bringing it
up yeah and and you know and I'm so
happy that you're well with kovid you
know you know that you're past it and
and I hope you don't have any uh
rebounds or
um I'm so scared of getting it I've
never had it and knock on wood I'd never
want it yep um but yeah no I'm so glad
in it it's always a pleasure to talk to
you the pleasure is all mine Sammy thank
you for the call oh thank you have a a
good day all right folks let's take a
very quick break but we're not done with
calls we're going right back to calls in
a moment I just need a very brief pause
and then we'll go right back to it stand
by